let's talk about Donald Trump's tax
returns there is no reason at this point
not to release Donald Trump's tax
returns the backstory is Trump is said
he's not going to release the tax
returns because they are under audit now
number one it's very unlikely that 2015
is already under audit it typically
takes a little longer for the IRS to put
a tax year under audit but he's not
gonna release 2015 we already know that
some prior years I think it's oh wait to
2012 the audits have been cleared he's
also not going to release those to be
perfectly clear number one nothing
prevents an American from releasing
their own tax returns whether you're
under audit or not Trump's argument is
he's been advised not to until all the
audits are done but there's no legal
issue whatsoever now former IRS
commissioner john moore who was opponent
appointed originally by president reagan
and then reappointed by george HW bush
and who has disclosed that he is voting
for Hillary Clinton this year he wrote a
long piece saying number one Trump
should release the tax returns voters
should get a look at them there could be
a lot learn from them as many have
already speculated Trump has really no
excuse not to release them other than
they would be damaging to his campaign
and more suggestions okay listen Donald
let's grant that there may be very
complicated things in some of the deeper
pages of your tax returns but release
just the first two pages of your form
1040 which is like the base federal tax
filing along with your schedule a from
the last 20 years and it would give us
the basics how much Donald Trump made
how much he paid in taxes and how much
he contributes to charity these are 33
of the interesting elements that some
speculate could be damaging to trump if
they were to be made public the IRS the
former IRS commissioner is very clear
that this would have no impact
whatsoever on any audits that may or may
not be going on we have similar data
from Hillary Clinton dating back 20
years and there is absolutely no reason
whatsoever not to release this and it is
becoming so clear now Louis that this is
calculated clearly Donald Trump is
calculated that releasing the tax
returns would
more damage than keeping them private
and to be perfectly honest if I were
Trump and I saw that I was down to
Hillary Clinton in 25 of the most recent
25 polls and I saw that it was very
unlikely that i was gonna win this thing
why would I release them if I'm going to
lose anyway I'd rather keep that
information private at this point yes or
you could take the Donald Trump on black
people approach and say what have you
got to lose if you're going to lose
anyway um maybe you should just release
it unless you know it'll hurt you even
more the that must be that's what we've
been speculating the whole time he knows
it will hurt him yeah so yes I suppose
at this point you just keep it under
wraps show us that tax returns Donald
let's take a look let's see if you're an
even bigger liar than you've already
been shown to be dozens of times after
dozens and dozens and dozens of times
what's one more lie you know the fact
that you didn't donate to charity or
that you're not as rich as you say you
are or whatever let's take a look at
those tax returns